[Music]
a surprise engagement on the bachelor
winter games world tells all reunion et
was backstage right after the big moment
to talk to the happy couple they didn't
start dating until after the show
stopped filming Claire Crawley got home
and received a text from a man she'd
turned down during the season Canadian
contestant Benoit it's unreal like I
can't club looking at it it's insane
it's insane girl I've waited 37 years
for this right hey and as you said you
waited for the right man for you
that's true is so true most of the
couples cast mates didn't even know they
were dating so why does this feel so
right
I think we're balancing each other this
is the best thing about the two of us is
definitely like we can really understand
where each other like we're coming from
I love him for him and his weirdnesses
and nuances and my weirdness is my
nemesis Benoit walk me through how you
surprised her with this proposal when
did you get the ring and how did you
pull all this off it was in my mind for
the past week and actually he didn't
have the the the one that I really
wanted so kneeling he had to make a new
one actually build a new one faster yeah
custom-made now they're figuring out
long distance and what's next it's hard
to always you know go through these
shows and people are like oh you look so
desperate to keep going on these shows
but it was never a desperation it was
always waiting for the right one
[Music]